his works have been taught for
generations but it seems there are still
lessons to be learnt about shakespeare
a london theater now plans to decolonize
his plays claiming that they are racist
for linking
whiteness to beauty well the globe
theatre has launched anti-racist
shakespeare seminars for teachers
students and theatre professionals they
are designed to address and i quote
problematic gendered and racialized
dynamics
activists claim that the playwright
promoted white as being positive
and dark is negative we put the issue up
for debate
they're decolonizing shakespeare maybe
they ought to decolonize the bible
i think what they're doing is
deliberately misunderstanding the use of
the word
fair and to mean beautiful it doesn't
have to mean
it doesn't have to mean blonde it
doesn't have to mean
white and to suddenly ascribe racial
values to it
um is just meaningless and over
sensitive
uh and and really going mad with the
whole issue
shakespeare yes he wrote in its time and
one can view it as being
political correctness but on the other
hand they are loaded words these days
and you know the the the uh i don't know
if it's the fairies or whatever was
was always a light character darkness is
always a sign
certainly in a eurocentric view of
wickedness and evil
one has to have some balance keep the
historical perspective
but also be sensitive to the needs of
young people who are listening and
watching this
and may make that connection with their
own ethnicity
gender and and complexion to draw
conclusions based on color
is just over sensitivity run mad but the
other point is
that the whole of history never mind
shakespeare but the whole of history
whether you go back to
churchill whether you go back to darwin
that they've been having a go at
in those days attitudes were different
now
we're not defending those attitudes i
think we have a better approach to all
these issues and we
we recognize the the underlying equality
of people in a way that wasn't the case
earlier but if we are to say well
we will abandon all literature and all
poetry
the views of a majority must again be
balanced with the sensitivity and needs
of the minorities in those audiences
and it is about changing the landscape
and not having a narrative
simply because it's 600 years old there
were chains
bullwhip rape that was the norm 600
years ago
we're not suggesting that that that is
uh
in a sense part of the experience today
someone has to be absolutely sensitive
to everybody in the audience and not
just
have a view of the traditionalists are
always right
you